in this video I'm going to show you
several astonishing lost maps of ancient
Africa and the Sahara which blew me away
as what's shown on these Maps is simply
not supposed to be possible and the
implications of which are absolutely
enormous as you'll see by the end of
this video and it's hard to know which
map to show you first so let me start by
asking why on Earth does a map that was
created closer to 500 years ago and
which also happens to be one of the
world's first ever maps to depict the
entire continent of Africa as a whole
clearly illustrate lakes rivers and even
a dense forest the size of Texas in the
middle of the Sahara Desert which
needless to say is obviously far
different than the vast Barren
Continental size desert that we all know
it for today and if you think it's odd
to see lakes rivers and Lush vegetation
in the Sahara wait until I show you what
else is hiding on this map later in the
video but first it must be mentioned
that considering that this map was
created by Sebastian moonster who has
been said to be one of the most
influential cartographers of the 16th
century as he was the first person to
print separate maps for each continent
around the world including not only of
Africa but that of Europe North and
South America which is rather
fascinating and he even produced the
first ever printed map of Asia so it
would seem to me that a map maker as
sophisticated and acclaimed to Sebastian
moonster would have had some reason to
explicitly detail the Sahara with a
diverse network of lakes rivers forests
instead of the inhospitable sandy desert
place that it is today and this caused
me to go down the so-called Rabbit Hole
In Search of the oldest maps of Africa
and I could not believe just how many
show the Sahara saturated with lakes
rivers and even numerous cities and
settlements scattered throughout the
region whether it be this striking map
created in 1482 by German printer
Lionheart hole and upon closer
inspection you can see not only rivers
and lakes but numerous cities blanketing
the entire region again what on Earth is
all of this doing in the middle of the
Sahara on a 500 year old map
in fact there are others which show
walled cities and even castles
throughout the region as well what
you're looking at here is the Catalan
Atlas a medieval world map from the year
1375 that was once within the Royal
Library of France and by the way that is
Mansa Musa of the Mali Empire the
richest man ever known to have existed
in all of human history in fact nearly
twice as wealthy as Elon Musk but that
aside the very nature of all these
cities in the middle of the Sahara
annotated on a map that is nearly 650
years old is intriguing to say the least
which brings me to an incredibly
astonishing world map created by Italian
cartographer from Murrow in the year
1450. first observe that is orientated
South so let me flip it over so you can
more easily get your bearings on the
direction Africa is facing but from here
let's again flip it back and observe the
Sahara from the original southernly
facing so you can distinctly see that
most of the Sahara is absolutely teeming
with cities where did all of these
civilizations go I have to say that I
find this map to be quite interesting
and I will come back to it later in this
video as there is a significant detail
that must be discussed but you must
first understand that there is no
shortage of these vintage maps of Africa
and the Sahara whether it be this one
from the year 1578 by renowned Flemish
cartographer gerardus Mercator which is
based on the work of ptolemae and as you
can clearly see annotates a river
Network traveling horizontally or east
and west through the Sahara or take this
map created by Italian engraver Fernando
Bertelli in 1565 which blatantly shows
three massive Lakes connected by a
Riverside system in fact if you go back
nearly six decades earlier you'll find
something quite thought-provoking which
is this massive world map created in the
year 1507 by The prominent German
cartographer Martin waltzmueller who by
the way is a guy that gave the so-called
New World the name America which
originates from this very map and upon a
closer inspection clearly shows the
Sahara Desert buzzing with cities that
follow along a system of rivers and
lakes again on a map that was created
more than 500 years ago
I think I'm starting to notice a pattern
here and if what I've showed you so far
isn't already strange enough this is
where things get even more interesting
and will continue to escalate through
the rest of the video now let me first
say that I am not suggesting that these
various five and six hundred year old
maps are actually depicting the Sahara
with lakes rivers and forests at that
time but rather that these maps are
evidence of a lost ancient knowledge of
what the Sahara was like between five
and possibly even more than ten thousand
years ago and here's how you know as I
have of course shared in multiple prior
videos scientists have only just learned
within the last decade through Modern
scientific studies that the Sahara
Desert was green and tropical as
recently as five and six thousand years
ago literally tens of thousands of years
more recently than previously thought
per the African humid period a truly
fascinating fact that surprises most
people when they hear it for the first
time as most all of us were taught that
the Sahara Desert was millions of years
years old which brings us to the
thought-provoking question which is why
is there a map created in the year 1502
literally showing a green Sahara this is
a Portuguese world map called the
cantino planosphere named after Alberto
cantino and smuggled to Italy from
Portugal well over 500 years ago
honestly how have I never seen or heard
of this map before and why on Earth does
it so blatantly display the Sahara with
such a lush tropical environment and if
you look closely you can clearly see the
details of trees and vegetation within
and again more than 5 000 years after a
green Sahara was last known to exist
which raises significant questions with
unbelievably profound scientific and
academic implications involving the
topic of climate history when you
consider that the mainstream scientific
understanding today is that these
ecological features including lakes
rivers grasslands and forests last
existed in the Sahara as far back as Phi
5 to 11
000 years ago according to the most
recent mainstream scientific sources
available and if that doesn't get you
thinking here is something that may blow
your mind which is the discovery of the
world's largest freshwater lake ever
known to exist was also located in the
middle of the Sahara and dates back 5
000 years and is referred to as Mega
Lake Chad which I have touched on in
Prior videos and real quick to put its
immense size into perspective the total
surface area of all the North American
Great Lakes combined equates to
approximately 94 000 square miles of
aggregate surface area whereas Lake Chad
equated to approximately 150
000 square miles of surface area all by
itself and here's where it gets even
more interesting besides the fact that
this Lake mysteriously dried up in a
matter of just a few hundred years this
Mega Lake existed 5 to 15
000 years ago now hold that thought and
let's revisit a couple maps that I just
showed you moments ago including the
1565 map of Fernando Bertelli as well as
the 1482 map of Lionheart Hall and tell
me that these two maps do not depict
this Lake just consider the general
region of Lake Chad's location which is
in modern day country of Chad and
compared to these old maps and now
consider this important detail which is
that Mega Lake Chad was actually the
largest of four paleo lakes in the
Sahara is that not what this map is
showing and inexplicably 500 years prior
to its Discovery in Modern Times And if
that isn't interesting enough consider
what I discussed moments ago related to
the various Maps I just showed you that
clearly annotate a network of rivers
traversing east and west through the
middle of the Sahara along with those
areas teeming with civilizations
including obvious cities and settlements
everywhere in between well isn't it
curious that a modern scientific study
from within just the last decade
identified a Paleo river system of three
large rivers that once existed in the
middle of the Sahara and would have
likely have supported ancient human
migration routes from 5 to 11
000 years ago so either Rivers existed
500 years ago in the Sahara or the
Ancients passed down knowledge of the
hair of the Saharas climate from several
thousand years ago and with that said it
must be mentioned that maps showing
rivers in the Sahara go back much
further than just five and six hundred
years ago as some of these maps are
actually based on the work of ptolemae
who created this map in the year 150 A.D
closer to 2000 years ago did this River
exist at that time or was ptolema
passing down ancient knowledge from even
older Source maps that may have existed
or been created thousands of years
before his time because let's not forget
that that's exactly how the periodies
map of 1513 came into existence as it
was comprised of more than 20 Source
maps from around the world and has
become one of the most highly debated
maps in existence as many believe that
it shows the coastline of Antarctica
some 300 years before Antarctica's
alleged Discovery in the year 1820
however many will adamantly say that
this map is simply showing the coastline
of the southernmost point of South
America this is something that I will be
discussing at length in my next video
but based on the modern scientific
studies it seems to me that these
various 500 year old maps are actually
based on older Source maps from five to
possibly even more than ten thousand
years ago when the Sahara was literally
a green tropical environment because
consider the from rural map of 1450 that
I discussed earlier and notice that it
specifically details the middle of the
Sahara as a desert at that time which I
would say is supportive evidence that
the green Sahara along with the rivers
and lakes were long since gone when this
map was created 500 plus years ago and
more likely suggests that these various
maps are showcasing lost ancient
knowledge of the Sahara from thousands
of years prior and if all of this isn't
compelling enough what I'm about to show
you now is what I consider to be the
proverbial nail in the coffin which
overwhelmingly indicates the existence
of this lost ancient knowledge which is
simply not supposed to be possible
consider the 1452 map of Sebastian
Munster and refocus your attention away
from the rivers lakes and forests and
observe what is shown in the western
Sahara and in the same geographical
location of the wristshot structure or
the eye of the Sahara as it's more
commonly called a spectacular geological
feature unlike any other on Earth and
perhaps one of the most mysterious and
bizarre structures in the world which I
have of course discussed at length on
this channel as I have compared its
striking similarities to the legend of
the lost city of Atlantis but never mind
the topic of Atlantis and consider one
thing and one thing only for a moment
which is the question as to whether this
map is showing the rishat while consumed
with water in fact here is a similar map
created by Heinrich bunting in the year
1581 which seemingly shows a river
leading from the Atlas Mountains in
North Africa and consuming the wrist
shot with water but if that's not
compelling enough take a look at this
other map of Northern Africa while under
the rule of the Roman Empire which again
seemingly details a river originating
from the Atlas Mountains and appears to
be arguably consumed the Rishad
structure with water based on its
circular nature and location and also
depicts it flowing out to the Atlantic
Ocean and this is where it gets wild
because we now know through recent
scientific studies that the ancient
Taman russet River flowed from the Atlas
Mountains and why did some 500
kilometers or just over 300 miles all
the way to the Atlantic and directly in
the path of the eye of the Sahara as far
back as 11 700 years ago before it
mysteriously dried up approximately five
thousand years ago and when you consider
better and unbelievably significant
detail which I shared in a recent video
which is that a modern study identified
the existence of Aquatic Life in the
rishat structure which included mollusks
and that date between 7715
000 years ago so think about that these
Maps May literally be depicting ancient
knowledge dating as far back as closer
to 8 000 years ago because the Rishad
did indeed have water in it at that time
and it seems to me that these two maps
are detailing the extinct Taman risset
river which once flowed through this
exact location so how and why is it
seemingly shown on these Maps five
thousand years after and real quick
while I'm at it does the nearly 700 year
old Catalan atlas map also show the
circular Rishad structure with water
flowing into it from the Atlas Mountains
perhaps as that is hard to say either
way and by the way going back to the
pure Reese map of 1513 most discussion
about it is focused entirely on whether
it depicts the coastline of Antarctica
however when you examine this map you
realize that it does show a small
portion of the Sahara which may also
show the wrist shot with water in it
based on the circular nature of this
feature you see here and seemingly with
a settlement in the middle which is in
the same general location of the wrist
shot that is certainly debatable and
maybe it is and maybe it isn't but is
something interesting and worthy of
mention as it is yet again on another
500 plus year old map but if you want to
see a particularly fascinating detail to
Pond over that I would consider to be
the epitome of bizarre let's go back to
the moonster map of 1452 and notice what
is Illustrated here
what on Earth is a giant white naked
one-eyed cyclops creature doing in the
middle of what is in modern day Nigeria
and Cameroon when I first saw this I was
like what is that
but it's most likely that several
hundred years ago European explorers
came across an elephant skull for the
first time and their fears and
imaginations went wild and to be fair if
you had no prior knowledge of the
existence of elephants and their unique
trunks it wouldn't be hard to assume
this was a giant one-eyed creature and
is also believed to be the origin of the
ancient Greek mythology for Cyclops but
I digress as I have to say that the only
thing Stranger than all the various maps
that I've shared with you throughout
this video is the fact that so few
people have ever even seen or heard of
them before but the very fact that
virtually none of them are taught in
school and that their contents are not
included in modern debates and for
involving Earth's climatical history it
seems to me that their absence in these
conversations is highly unfortunate
honestly I think these Maps stand to
upend much of the modern discussion of
our climate which has sadly become
highly political in recent times I mean
where did all of the rivers lakes
forests and cities is in the middle of
the Sahara go definitely leave a comment
and share your thoughts and everything
that's been discussed in this video are
these maps showing evidence of a lost
ancient knowledge that from several
thousand years earlier involving Earth's
climatical history or is it possible
that the Sahara desert's climate was
vastly different to some five and six
hundred years ago definitely something
fun to think about but with all that
said my name is Jimmy corsetti my
channel is called bright Insight hit the
like button and subscribe and stay tuned
for my next video which I suspect is
going to be incredibly thought provoking
for many people all that said take care
everyone